hier also hier beginnt die zukunft der
arzneimittelforschung hier bei sanofi
werden vollkommen neue medikamente
entwickelt sie basieren auf antikörpern
hier sind es proteine und um dann genau
den richtigen antikörper zu bauen das
geschieht hier in den laboren braucht es
mächtige computer künstliche intelligenz
hier werden also die zukünftigen hoch
wirkungsvolle medikamente entwickelt die
zum beispiel viel besser gegen krebs
wirken weg zum science fiction hier gibt
es täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen herzlich
willkommen bei sanofi treffe ich den
pharmakologen dr norbert hüttmann
das hier ist das herz der forschung
diese von robotern gesteuerte maschine
kann bis zu 10.000 proteine in einem
rutsch untersuchen und dann analysiert
künstliche intelligenz die ergebnisse
möglich werden diese mengen durch das so
genannte platten format die arbeiten im
platten format weil wir uns sehr viele
moleküle auf einmal angucken wollen und
mehr finden praktisch pro ja kavität
oder pro ausstellungen in dieser platte
schauen wir uns ein molekül an das kann
man sich vorstellen wie jedes ist quasi
ein reagenz welchen genau wir haben
praktisch 96 kleine reagenz röhrchen in
dieser platte und die ergebnisse in
dieser massentests können dann mit
künstlicher intelligenz auf zahlreiche
werte untersucht werden ein
quantensprung in der forschung dadurch
dass für 10.000 moleküle pro kampagne
herstellen und diese moleküle auch auf
unterschiedlichste eigenschaften
charakterisieren generieren wir
riesengroßen datensätze und da wollen
wir natürlich auch daraus lernen weil
das ist eigentlich einer der der der
game changer in der entwicklung von
komplexen biopharmazeutika dass man die
moleküle auch versteht die künstliche
intelligenz hilft uns dann wenn wir
dieses ganze diesen riesengroßen
datenschatz zusammengestellt haben
vielleicht zu erkennen dass es
systematisch zusammenhänge gibt die uns
dann in einem follow up projekt in den
beiden folgenden projekt hilft unsere
experimente schon so zu planen dass
vielleicht viele von den unguten
varianten direkt ausschließen können und
dadurch können wirklich komplett neue
erkenntnisse erworben werden die quasi
aus den daten punkten nur könnt sie hier
intelligenz ist dazu so in der lage was
hier passiert
dass wir die baupläne schon den zellen
gegeben haben und die einzelnen
varianten sind schon hergestellt worden
denn jedem von diesen 96 gefäßen ist
eine neue variante ein molekül generiert
worden und die haben wir uns dann etwas
genauer angesehen um zu gucken haben wir
denn da auch viel versprechende
varianten hergestellt und wir haben in
der tat ein paar gefunden die uns sehr
gut gefallen haben und was jetzt hier
gerade passiert ist dass der roboter
sich die die varianten die uns richtig
gut gefallen haben wir haben eben die
arbeitsanweisung gegeben er soll die
guten mal raussuchen damit wir die noch
umfassender anschauen können das ganze
ist wirklich ein riesenfortschritt durch
robotik in verbindung mit künstlicher
intelligenz ist hier ein tempo in der
forschung möglich wie es vor jahren
undenkbar war diese moleküle müssen aber
auch irgendwie hergestellt werden und
das ist nicht mehr mit gewöhnlichen
chemischen prozessen möglich die
proteine sind einfach viel zu komplex
deshalb werden dafür zellen genommen
also das ist jetzt quasi ich sag mal
unprofessionell suppe also die zellen
die nachher die moleküle produzieren
genau also wir haben die zellen die sich
in der nährlösung gerade befinden
die brauchen wir als die die fabriken
für unsere multi okay und normal zu
diesen molekülen
ja das sind ja ganz besondere moleküle
erstens mal die sind riesig wie genau es
also wir reden über große eiweißmoleküle
im speziellen antikörper mit denen wir
uns hier beschäftigen und wenn man jetzt
so von normalen kleinen chemischen
wirkstoffen ausgeht sind diesen faktor
1000 größer und deshalb sind wir auch
nicht mehr in der lage das chemische
prozesse herzustellen sondern wir nutzen
hier biologische prozesse und eben die
die fälle als fabrik die dann anhand von
dem bauplan uns diese sehr komplexen
moleküle hersteller
sie macht das kleine ich sag mal eine
fabrik drinnen oder grillen sind ja
total drüber natur aus stellen zählen ja
schon eine menge von proteinen her und
ja wir versuchen das über die baupläne
so zu steuern dass nicht irgendwelche
proteine hergestellt werden sondern
genau diese therapeutischen proteinen
die wir gerne als arzneistoffe benutzen
berichten das heißt sie sind wirklich
zehntausende oder bei ihnen der maschine
landes bis zu 10.000 unterschiedliche
moleküle werden 10.000 unterschiedliche
antikörper oder andere therapeutische
proteine diese antikörper sind eiweiße
nennt man auch genau warum sind die
jetzt so groß ich meine wenn ich eine
tablette gegen kopfschmerzen nehme das
ist ja auch ein kleines molekül er in
die biologischen größere moleküle
bringen den vorteil mit sich dass die
wechselwirkung mit dem partner der die
krankheit auslöst oder in den
krankheitsprozess eingebunden ist sehr
viel spezifischer und zielgerichteter
ist dh wir haben weniger interaktionen
mit anderen proteinen die wir vielleicht
gar nicht adressieren wollen das heißt
man kann quasi maßgeschneiderte
medikamente herstellen
genau maßgeschneiderte als kleine motive
ok also immer noch nicht perfekt aber
die medizin wird sich also in den
nächsten jahrzehnten massiv verändern
und wir werden medikamente verwenden
können die krankheiten viel
zielgerichteter bekämpfen ich bin extrem
gespannt was es dann in ein paar jahren
alles für medikamente geben wird heilung
für malaria in sicht neue impfung da
gibt es schon jetzt ein neues medikament
einen neuen impfstoff auf das video hier
klicken anschauen und der medizinstudent
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran